hi everyone it's Jared I have an
excellent game to share with you from
the ongoing TP Sigmund and Company
tournament
this is a round two game between two
very talented top 10 Juniors on the
white and duquesh and he's up against
Vincent kymer
digukash is knocking on the door of a
world's top ten
very patient play by both players in
this one Roy Lopez on board
for a few moves in this game black has
the option to take on e4 and in each
case the reply D4 is good
trying to open the position while the
black king is still in the center
black goes for the Archangel variation
when given a kick
white Ops for the more active
deployment the more active post for the
bishop rather than defend E4 directly
white says I have a trick up my sleeve
in cases where you might bite on eform
first D6 D4 Bishop B6 now in my
introduction when I said
very patient play I had an image in mind
and it is these guys right here nope
this tension and how long it's present
in this game
why is it present for so long well
neither side
feels that they are benefiting by
releasing the tension
around move 12 we're going to have a
closer look at the different paths this
game could have taken should one side or
the other have released the tension
for now more development Bishop E3
I said that white has a trick up his
sleeve this guy does
in the event of Knight takes E4
white would have Bishop D5
both of these are hanging there's a fork
white wins a piece
so this guy's poison black castles
Knight B to D2
rookie eight
hinting at a possible capture on D4 and
then Knight takes E4
still no problem for white he goes with
H3
this would not be a good decision for
black to
chop away and then take on e4 because
white does not care if it is a knight or
Rook on e4 you're still getting forked
okay White's still cool on e4
with H3 he's stopping any Knight G4
Bishop's more secure white enjoys the
flight Square as well black says I too
can play that game I got my flight
Square
this game feels very much like a game of
inches like we're observing a Jiu Jitsu
match each side for many moves in this
game is slowly trying to improve their
position while at the same time not
giving an inch not extending their arm
not leaving themselves vulnerable
for example to an arm bar
slow methodical play
in this game is Queen E2 Rook B8 with
these last two moves each side is in a
position to recapture
on E3 or B6 the dark Square Bishops are
secure with pieces
now instead of Rook to B8 this is where
I want to highlight one of the
structural changes and it kicks off with
Black's decision
what's going to happen if black releases
the tension how might play follow
if black instead of playing with B8
captured on D4 this is how play could
continue
Knight A5
hitting the bishop
so that
this guy could contribute to challenging
whites
panduo
I'm going to take it out just a hair
further
there's an instinctual error I made in
preparing for this video and one of the
variations and that is
after this capture instinctually I went
with
the pawn as the recapture but that's no
good
because after E5 the Knight will have to
move
however if you first take with the
bishop
these guys are exchanged E5 this guy is
pinned
this is not yet a threat and it says
after Bishop B7 it's around an even
position
okay
that's one way the game could have
turned
in this game it's Rook B8 let's look at
the other two
white has two options to take or push
let's say white captures this one's
a much shorter variation
black would recapture at the Knight
keep this as a half open file for now
and it also frees the C pun
in the event of
white ducking This Night Exchange let's
say tries to go to D4
hinting at F4 there would be C5
but let's say the capture now black
could recapture at the pawn
and there's no benefit
it's considered an even position here so
this is a reason to not be
not be releasing the tension as white
this guy still sticks around here on D4
what other way might it change this is
the last one and that is to give this
Knight a kick to close the center
this is the
this is a variation where black is
actually going to be the side who
benefits and let's have a closer look
as to why that is the case
now in playing D5 as white
what might you be saying
you're saying that you're okay
exchanging your good Bishop for blacks
bad Bishop
that's one way of looking at it
and here's another one
this guy right now with the pawn on D4
you might describe this bishop as not
only your good Bishop potentially but
as a two-directional bishop it's
functioning on the queen side and King
side whereas this guy right here
it's only a one-directional bishop
sees just just along this diagonal
this difference matters
we're going to see that this guy right
here is extremely dangerous and this is
made possible because of The Patience by
white the patience with this decision
this guy does not budge white does not
give black an opportunity to exchange
dark Square Bishops
okay
if we're to carry out this variation why
does it prefer black here
mainly because
black is going to have an easier time
activating the Rooks has an easier time
getting a pawn Break in with F5
okay in this game tension remains
continue to slowly build up computer
points out you could still go for the
capture however it's less attractive now
seeing how this Rook is now opposite the
queen
okay
from here Bishop to D7 this earlier
trick I was pointing out with Bishop to
D5
that's no longer there now that this
Knight is defended
this is what prompts White's next move
Bishop C2 it's there to defend E4
this time directly
okay from here Queen C8
this is where things start to get a
little bit away
from black I feel
Black's moving the queen like a king
going to C8
going to B8 or excuse me B7 and then
making some Pawn advances on the queen
side eventually
uh what we're going to see in action
here is black is playing on the queen
side obtaining some static pluses
whereas white is drifting towards the
king side we're going to see a night
maneuver
and the pieces are slowly starting to
improve and there's a storm brewing on
the king's side
okay
static pluses for black on the queen
side Dynamic pluses for white on the
king side
from here Rook F to E1
centralization vacated Square for the
king Knight excuse me the queen Knight
Queen B7
A3 again
a game of inches
you might think
you know when you play this move what's
the natural follow-up you play this
shouldn't now be the time you go for
this maneuver not so fast
A3 is flicked in for two reasons One
Stop upon break B4
two cut out any possibility of Knight B4
this guy on C3 is not a reliable
defender of B4
let's see what might happen if this
Knight immediately looks to on this move
to go to F1
here's how play could follow black could
take on D4
take on e4
and after this push D5
dark Square bishops get exchanged this
Knight has access to
the B4 Square
Bishop backs off and now there's moves
like Knight to F6 and you could go
hunting this is a way for black to play
this one
the B4 Square in short is available to
Black
okay
first it's A3
A5 only now Knight F1 how is this
different
if black in this position captures on D4
in the game
A4 is played
let's compare
this position with a3n before moving the
Knight to F1
if black takes in this case
Chop Chop Knight takes E4 D5 notice the
difference here
what options does this guy have on C6
now
the computer says best is to go to A7
black is up a pawn but the quality of
this Knight is not very good
this is a this is still considered a
very good position for white
okay
from here it's A4
more long term if this maybe gets into
an ending the Queens are maybe exchanged
this idea of the A3 B2 pawns being
clamped the A4 like this
this could be a nice positive for black
but we're a long ways away from having a
queen Exchange
there's an attack coming towards the
black king Knight G3 Knight A5 Knight H4
Knight C4 Bishop is fine Bishop on C1 is
developed
it's not in the way the queen Rook
it's canceling out the night
still has an eye
on the H6 Square
D5
considered best at this stage for black
is to release the tension
and then go with C5
trying to open up this Square for the
Knight for instance if D5 the computer
is saying to fall back here you're going
to need some defense of your king side
this is not the way
uh black plays in this position he goes
with D5 so a lot of tension now in the
center white is better prepared for this
opening up of the position better
positioned with the pieces
from here Queen F3
Knight to D6 and here we have the
sacrifice on H6
this guy
is overloaded had two jobs
black saw this coming he had prepared
this capture and reply but
light has seen further Queen gets out of
the way while also defending H6 Bishop
is picked up
Queen takes notice the big difference in
this position between the Queens
she's way over here in left field
nowhere close to trying
nowhere in position not even close to
neutralizing the White Queen
in this game rookie 6 as the follow-up
Knight F5 I questioned does it matter
which Knight you go into the F5 square
with
um this is the better night to go in
and a reason for this is to have this
maneuver available it's important to
have in one of the lines
uh
the G3 Square open for The Rook so it's
better to go with this guy first
Knight F5 Knight G2 F5
we are threatening well it was
threatening made on G7
Queen G5 check
ing f8
Queen H5
I should mention that there's a couple
reasons why this move is no good one we
could take it with the Knight and two
there's this Fork on E7
so
the reason I'm highlighting this is
because in this position right here when
the Knight drops into F5 black could
have first exchanged a pair of knights
and then if black defends like this
the check still can't be met with that
we got the fork going on
okay in this game after Knight F5
it's immediately
the retreat
Knight F to E8
from here Queen G5 check king f8 queen
H5 threatening maintenance one
Knight takes Knight Knight takes Knight
Rook G6 just there in time
to stop the mate
The Rook is ready to block in the event
of Queen h8
so Bishop takes E4
Queen A7
and
we go for a check only one move another
check Knight blocks chop chop black is
in a pin and all white needs to do is
take advantage of it
there are two ways you could get a rook
to G3
which one would you go for instinctually
as an attacking player do you go with
Rook D3 or Rook E3 again it doesn't
matter in the computer's eyes but I
think the more human move here is
this guy going to E3 the reason I think
this is because this guy
maybe has in mind a capture of the
bishop in some lines it is unprotected
on D7
and this guy right here we really don't
need
uh the support of the bishop on e4
okay either way both are very good both
are winning at this stage the queen is
not going to be able to assist in
defending the black king so
let's try it as Bishop G4
trying to close the G file you could
take the bishop but even better is the
move played in the game Rook G3
and after Bishop takes
on D4 Rook takes bishop and that's the
final move of the game
black resigns there's no way to defend
the pinned Rook
if some other move is played here I
should mention instead of Bishop to G4
if the King goes to G8
we could play Rook to G1 still
and there's still going to be a problem
here on G7
if you take the Rook we would end up
with the familiar Checkmate pattern
Bishop H7
Bishop G6 discover check check checkmate
so no good uh answer here for black in
this case he went with Bishop G4
and after Rook takes G4 this one is over
so a very nice game by again two very
very talented top 10 juniors
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below I hope you enjoyed it and maybe
took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye